MATTERS IS IF WE'RE GOING TO
LISTEN, IS HE ACTUALLY GOING OOB
ABLE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE IN
CONGRESS.
HERE IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPEAKING --
>> MEMORIAL DAY, THIS PAST
MONDAY.
JILL AND I VISITED ARLINGTON
NATIONAL CEMETERY.
AS WE ENTERED THOSE HALLOWED
GROUNDS, WE SAW ROWS AND ROWS OF
CROSSES, AMONG THE ROWS OF
HEADSTONES OF OTHER EMBLEMS OF
BELIEF, HONORING THOSE WHO PAYED
THE ULTIMATE PRICE ON
BATTLEFIELDS AROUND THE WORLD.
THE THE DAY BEFORE, WE VISITED
UVALDE, UVALDE TEXAS.
IN FRONT OF ROB ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL, WE STOOD BEFORE 21
CROSSES FOR 19 THIRD AND FOURTH
GRADERS AND TWO TEACHERS.
ON EACH CROSS, A NAME.
AND NEARBY, A PHOTO OF EACH
VICTIM THAT JILL AND I REACHED
OUT TO TOUCH.
INNOCENT VICTIMS, MURDERED IN A
CLASSROOM, THAT HAD BEEN TURNED
INTO A KILLING FIELD.
STANDING THERE IN THAT SMALL
TOWN, LIKE SO MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES ACROSS AMERICA, I
COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK, THERE
ARE TOO MANY OTHER SCHOOLS, TOO
MANY OTHER EVERYDAY PLACES THAT
HAVE BECOME KILLING FIELDS,
BATTLEFIELDS.
HERE IN AMERICA.
WE STOOD IN SUCH A PLACE 12 DAYS
BEFORE.
ACROSS FROM A GROCERY STORE IN
BUFFALO, NEW YORK, MEMORIALIZING
10 FELLOW AMERICANS, A SPOUSE,
PARENT, GRANDPARENT, A SIBLING,
GONE FOREVER.
AND BOTH PLACES, WE SPENT HOURS
WITH HUNDREDS OF FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO WERE BROKEN AND WHOSE LIVES
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME.
THEY HAD ONE MESSAGE FOR ALL OF
US -- DO SOMETHING.
JUST DO SOMETHING.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, DO SOMETHING.
AFTER COLUMBINE, AFTER SANDY
HOOK, AFTER CHARLESTON, AFTER
ORLANDO, AFTER LAS VEGAS, AFTER
PARKLAND, NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE.
THIS TIME, THAT CAN'T BE TRUE.
THIS TIME, WE MUST ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING.
THE ISSUE WE FACE IS ONE OF
CONSCIENCE AND COMMON SENSE.
FOR SO MANY OF YOU AT HOME, I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT TAKING AWAY
ANYONE'S GUNS, IT'S NOT ABOUT
VILIFYING GUN OWNERS.
IN FACT, WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE
TREATING RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS
AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW EVERY GUN
OWNER SHOULD BEHAVE.
I RESPECT THE CULTURE AND THE
TRADITION, THE CONCERNS OF
LAWFUL GUN OWNERS.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, LIKE ALL OTHER RIGHTS
IS NOT ABSOLUTE.
IT WAS JUSTICE CELIA WHO WROTE
AND I QUOTE, LIKE MOST RIGHTS,
THE RIGHT, SECOND AMENDMENT, THE
RIGHTS GRANTED BY THE SECOND
AMENDMENT ARE NOT UNLIMITED.
NOT UNLIMITED.
IT NEVER HAS BEEN.
THERE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
LIMITATIONS ON WHAT WEAPONS YOU
CAN OWN IN AMERICA.
FOR EXAMPLE, MACHINE GUNS HAVE
BEEN FEDERALLY REGULATED FOR
NEARLY 90 YEARS AND THIS IS
STILL A FREE COUNTRY.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT TAKING AWAY
ANYONE'S RIGHTS.
SO I'M PROTECTING CHILDREN.
PROTECTING FAMILIES.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING WHOLE
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
FREEDOMS TO GO TO SCHOOL, TO A
GROCERY STORE, TO A CHURCH,
WITHOUT BEING SHOT AND KILLED.
ACCORDING TO NEW DATA JUST
RELEASED BY CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION, GUNS ARE
THE NUMBER ONE KILLER OF
CHILDREN IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
NUMBER ONE KILLER.
MORE THAN CAR ACCIDENTS, MORE
THAN CANCER.
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES, MORE
SCHOOL-AGE CHILDREN HAVE DIED
FROM GUNS THAN ON DUTY POLICE
OFFICERS AND ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY COMBINED.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
MORE KIDS THAN ON DUTY COPS
KILLED BY GUNS.
MORE KIDS THAN SOLDIERS KILLED
BY GUNS.
FOR GOD'S SAKE.
HOW MUCH MORE CARNAGE ARE WE
WILLING TO ACCEPT?
HOW MANY MORE INNOCENT AMERICAN
LIVES MUST BE TAKEN BEFORE WE
SAY ENOUGH.
ENOUGH.
I KNOW THAT WE CAN'T PREVENT
EVERY TRAGEDY, BUT HERE'S WHAT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO DO.
HERE'S WHAT THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF AMERICAN PEOPLE
BELIEVE WE MUST DO.
HERE'S WHAT THE FAMILIES IN
BUFFALO AND UVALDE, IN TEXAS,
TOLD US WE MUST DO.
WE NEED TO BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS
AND HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
AND IF WE CAN'T BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS, WE SHOULD RAISE THE AGE
TO PURCHASE THEM FROM 18 TO 21.
STRENGTHEN BACKGROUND CHECKS,
ENACT SAFE STORAGE LAW AND RED
FLAG LAWS.
REPEAL THE IMMUNITY TO PROTECTS
GUN MANUFACTURERS FROM
LIABILITY.
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS, THE TRAUMA FROM GUN
VIOLENCE AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE RATIONAL, COMMON SENSE
MEASURES.
HERE'S WHAT IT ALL MEANS.
IT ALL MEANS THIS -- WE SHOULD
REINSTATE THE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN ON HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES
WE PASSED IN 1994 WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN CONGRESS
AND THE SUPPORT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
NINE CATEGORIES OF SEMI
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS WERE INCLUDED
IN THAT BAN, LIKE AK-47S AND
AR-15s AND THE TEN YEARS IT WAS
LAW, MASS SHOOTINGS WENT DOWN.
BUT AFTER REPUBLICANS LET THE
LAW EXPIRE IN 2004, THOSE
WEAPONS WERE ALLOWED TO BE SOLD
AGAIN, MASS SHOOTINGS TRIPLED.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
A FEW YEARS AGO, FAMILY OF THE
INVENTOR OF THE AR-15 SAID HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN HORRIFIED TO
KNOW HIS DESIGN WAS BEING USED
TO SLAUGHTER CHILDREN AND OTHER
INNOCENT LIVES INSTEAD OF BEING
USED AS A MILITARY WEAPON ON THE
BATTLEFIELDS AS IT WAS DESIGNED.
ENOUGH.
WE SHOULD LIMIT HOW MANY ROUNDS
A WEAPON CAN HOLD.
WHY IN GOD'S NAME SHOULD AN
ORDINARY CITIZEN BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE AN ASSAULT WEAPON THAT
HOLDS 30 ROUND MAGAZINES THAT
LET MASS SHOOTERS FIRE HUNDREDS
OF BULLETS IN A MATTER OF
MINUTES.
THE DAMAGE WAS SO DEVASTATING IN
UVALDE, PARENTS HAD TO DO DNA
SWABS TO IDENTIFY THE REMAINS OF
THEIR CHILDREN.
NINE AND 10-YEAR-OLD CHILDREN.
ENOUGH.
WE SHOULD EXPAND BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF FELONS, FUGITIVES AND
THOSE UNDER RESTRAINING ORDERS.
STRONGER BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE
SOMETHING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS, INCLUDING THE
MAJORITY OF GUN OWNERS AGREE ON.
I ALSO BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE
SAFE STORAGE LAWS, PERSONAL
RELIABILITY FOR NOT LOCKING UP
YOUR GUN.
THE SHOOTER AT SANDY HOOK CAME
FROM A HOME FULL OF GUNS.
THEY WERE TOO EASY TO ACCESS.
THAT'S HOW HE GOT THE WEAPONS.
THE WEAPON HE USED TO KILL HIS
MOTHER, AND THEN MURDER 26
PEOPLE INCLUDING 20 FIRST
GRADERS.
IF YOU OWN A WEAPON, YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SECURE IT.
EVERY RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNER
AGREES.
MAKE SURE NO ONE ELSE CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO IT.
TO LOCK IT UP.
TO HAVE TRIGGER LOCKS.
AND IF YOU DON'T, AND SOMETHING
BAD HAPPENS, YOU SHOULD BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
WE SHOULD ALSO HAVE NATIONAL RED
FLAG LAWS SO THAT A PARENT, A
TEACHER, A COUNSELLOR CAN FLAG
FOR A COURT THAT A CHILD, A
STUDENT, A PATIENT, IS
EXHIBITING VIOLENT TENDENCIES,
THREATENING CLASSMATES OR
EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS,
MAKES THEM A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR TO OTHERS.
19 STATES IN THE DISTRICT
COLUMBIA HAVE RED FLAG LAWS.
THE DELAWARE LAWS, TO MY SON,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BO BIDEN.
TEXAS, 2009, 13 DEAD, 30
INJURED, MARJORIE STONE DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL IN PARKLAND FLORIDA,
17 DEAD, 17 INJURED.
IN BOTH PLACES, COUNTLESS OTHERS
SUFFERING WITH INVISIBLE WOUNDS.
RED FLAG LAWS COULD HAVE STOPPED
BOTH THESE SHOOTERS.
IN UVALDE, THE SHOOTER WAS 17
WHEN HE ASKED HIS SISTER TO BUY
AN ASSAULT WEAPON, KNOWING HE'D
BE DENIED BECAUSE HE WAS TOO
YOUNG TO PURCHASE ONE HIMSELF,
SHE REFUSED.
BUT AS SOON AS HE TURNED 18, HE
PURCHASED TWO ASSAULT WEAPONS
FOR HIMSELF BECAUSE IN TEXAS,
YOU CAN BE 18 YEARS OLD AND BUY
AN ASSAULT WEAPON EVEN THOUGH
YOU CAN'T BUY A PISTOL IN TEXAS
UNTIL YOU'RE 21.
IF WE CAN'T BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS
AS WE SHOULD, WE MUST AT LEAST
RAISE THE AGE TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE ONE TO 21.
LOOK, I KNOW SOME FOLKS WILL SAY
18-YEAR-OLDS CAN SERVE IN THE
MILITARY, AND FIRE THOSE
WEAPONS, BUT THAT'S WITH
TRAINING AND SUPERVISION BY THE
BEST-TRAINED EXPERTS IN THE
WORLD.
DON'T TELL ME RAISING THE AGE
WON'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
ENOUGH.
WE SHOULD REPEAL THE LIABILITY
SHIELD THAT OFTEN PROTECTS GUN
MANUFACTURERS FROM BEING SUED
FOR THE DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
CAUSED BY THEIR WEAPONS.
THEY'RE THE ONLY INDUSTRY IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT HAS THAT KIND
OF IMMUNITY.
IMAGINE IF THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
HAD BEEN IMMUNE FROM BEING SUED
WHERE IT WOULD BE TODAY.
THE GUN INDUSTRY SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS ARE OUTRAGEOUS.
IT MUST END.
LET THERE BE NO MISTAKE WITH THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA THAT GUN
VIOLENCE LEAVES BEHIND.
IMAGINE BEING THAT LITTLE GIRL,
THAT BRAVE LITTLE GIRL IN UVALDE
WHO SMEARED BLOOD OFF HER
MURDERED FRIEND'S BODY ON HER
OWN FACE TO LIE STILL AMONG THE
CORPSES IN HER CLASSROOM AND
PRETEND SHE WAS DEAD IN ORDER TO
STAY ALIVE.
IMAGINE, IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD
BE LIKE FOR HER TO WALK DOWN
IT'S HALLWAY OF ANY SCHOOL
AGAIN.
IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR
CHILDREN WHO EXPERIENCE THIS
KIND OF TRAUMA EVERYDAY IN
SCHOOL, ON THE STREETS, IN
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR SO
MANY PARENTS TO HUG THEIR
CHILDREN GOODBYE IN THE MORNING,
NOT SURE WHETHER THEY'LL COME
BACK HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY, TOO MANY PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE THAT AT
ALL.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, PEOPLE
WERE ALREADY HURTING.
THERE'S A SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
THAT'S WHY MENTAL HEALTH IS AT
THE HEART OF MY UNITY AGENDA
THAT I'VE LAYED OUT IN THE STATE
OF THE UNION ADDRESS THIS YEAR.
WE MUST PROVIDE MORE SCHOOL
COUNSELLORS, MORE SCHOOL NURSES,
MORE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS.
MORE PEOPLE VOLUNTEERING AS
MENTORS TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
SUCCEED, MORE PROCESSING
PROTECTION AND RESOURCES TO KEEP
KIDS SAFE FROM THE HARMS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS YOU KNEW, UNITY AGENDA
WON'T FULLY HEAL THE WOUNDED
SOULS BUT IT HELPS, IT MATTERS.
I TOLD YOU WHAT I'LL DO, THE
QUESTION NOW IS WHAT WILL THE
CONGRESS TO?
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES ALREADY
PASSED KEY MEASURES WE NEED,
EXPANDING BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
COVER NEARLY ALL GUN SALES
INCLUDING AT GUN SHOWS AND
ONLINE SALES.
GETTING RID OF A LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
A GUNSALE TO GO THROUGH AFTER
THREE BUSINESS DAYS EVEN IF THE
BACKGROUND CHECK HAS NOT BEEN
COMPLETED.
PLANNING EVEN MORE ACTION NEXT
WEEK.
SAFE STORAGE REQUIREMENTS.
THE BANNING OF HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES, RAISE THE AGE TO BUY
AN ASSAULT WEAPON TO 21.
FEDERAL RED FLAG LAW, CODIFYING
MY BAN ON GHOST GUNS THAT DON'T
HAVE SERIAL NUMBERS AND CAN'T BE
TRACED.
THIS TIME, WE HAVE TO TAKE THE
TIME TO DO SOMETHING, THIS TIME,
IT'S TIME FOR THE SENATE TO DO
SOMETHING.
BUT AS WE KNOW, IN ORDER TO DO,
TO GET ANYTHING DONE IN THE
SENATE, WE NEED A MINIMUM OF 10
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
I SUPPORT THE BIPARTISAN EFFORTS
THAT INCLUDE SMALL GROUP OF
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICAN SENATORS
TRYING TO FIND A WAY, BUT MY
GOD.
THE FACT THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THE SENATE REPUBLICANS DON'T
WANT ANY OF THESE PROPOSALS EVEN
TO BE DEBATED OR COME UP FOR A
VOTE, I FIND UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE CAN'T FAIL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AGAIN.
SINCE UVALDE, JUST OVER A WEEK
AGO, THERE HAVE BEEN 20 OTHER
MASS SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA, EACH
WITH FOUR OR MORE PEOPLE KILLED
OR INJURED, INCLUDING YESTERDAY,
AT A HOSPITAL IN TULSA,
OKLAHOMA, SHOOTER DELIBERATELY
TARGETED A SURGEON USING AN
ASSAULT WEAPON HE BOUGHT JUST A
FEW HOURS BEFORE HIS RAMPAGE
THAT LEFT A SURGEON, ANOTHER
DOCTOR, RECEPTIONIST AND PATIENT
DEAD AND MANY MORE INJURED.
THAT DOESN'T COUNT THE CARNAGE
WE SEE EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THE HEADLINES.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS FIGHT FOR A
LONG TIME.
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS, BUT I'LL
NEVER GIVE UP AND IF CONGRESS
FAILS, I BELIEVE THIS TIME, A
MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WON'T GIVE UP EITHER.
I BELIEVE THE MAJORITY OF YOU
WILL ACT AND TURN YOUR OUTRAGE
INTO MAKING THIS ISSUE CENTRAL
TO YOUR VOTE.
ENOUGH, ENOUGH, ENOUGH.
OVER THE NEXT 17 DAYS, THE
FAMILIES IN UVALDE WILL CONTINUE
BURYING THEIR DEAD.
WILL TAKE THAT LONG IN PART WAS
IT'S A TOWN WHERE EVERYONE KNOWS
EVERYONE AND DAY BY DAY, THEY
WILL HONOR EACH ONE THEY LOST.
JILL AND I MET WITH THE OWNER
AND STAFF FROM THE FUNERAL HOME,
BEING STRONG, STRONG, STRONG TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN.
AND THE PEOPLE OF UVALDE MOURNED
AS THEY DO OVER THE NEXT 17
DAYS.
WHAT WILL WE BE DOING AS A
NATION?
JILL AND I MET WITH THE SISTER
OF THE TEACHER WHO WAS MURDERED
AND WHOSE HUSBAND DIED OF A
HEART ATTACK TWO DAYS LATER,
LEAVING BEHIND FOUR BEAUTIFUL
ORPHANED CHILDREN.
ALL NOW ORPHANS.
THE SISTER ASKED US, WHAT COULD
SHE SAY?
WHAT COULD SHE TELL HER NIECES
AND NEPHEWS?
THE MOST HEARTBREAKING MOMENTS
THAT I CAN REMEMBER.
ALL I COULD THINK TO SAY WAS I
TOLD HER TO HOLD THEM TIGHT.
HOLD THEM TIGHT.
IN THE VISIT TO THE SCHOOL, WE
TENDED MASS AT CATHOLIC HEART
CHURCH MASS, IN THE PEWS, FAMILY
AND FRIENDS HELD EACH OTHER
TIGHTLY AS THE ARCH BISHOP
SPOKE, HE ASKED THE CHILDREN IN
ATTENDANCE TO COME UP TO ALTAR
AND SIT AT THE ALTAR WITH THEM,
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH ROOM SO MOM
AND HER YOUNG SON SAT NEXT TO
JILL AND ME IN THE FIRST PEW AND
AS WE LEFT THE CHURCH,
GRANDMOTHER WHO JUST LOST HER
GRANDDAUGHTER PASSED ME A
HAND-WRITTEN LETTER, IT READ,
ERASE THE INVISIBLE LINE THAT IS
DIVIDING OUR NATION.
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION AND FIX
WHAT'S BROKEN AND MAKE THE
CHANGES NECESSARY TO PREVENT
THIS HAPPENING AGAIN, END OF
QUOTE.
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, ENOUGH.
ENOUGH.
IT'S TIME FOR EACH OF US TO DO
OUR PART.
IT'S TIME TO ACT.
FOR THE CHILDREN WE'VE LOST, FOR
THE CHILDREN WE CAN SAVE, FOR
THE NATION WE LOVE.
LET'S HEAR THE CALL AND THE CRY.
LET'S MEET THE MOMENT.
LET US FINALLY DO SOMETHING.
GOD BLESS THE FAMILIES WHO ARE
HURTING.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
FROM THE 91st PSALM IN MY
CHURCH, MAY HE RAISE YOU ON
EAGLE'S WINGS AND BURY YOU ON
THE BREATH OF DAWN, MAY HE SHINE
YOU LIKE THE SUN AND HOLD YOU IN
THE PALM OF HIS HAND.
THAT'S MY PRAYER F